à l'extérieur on entend le chant des
oiseaux mais une fois passé les portes
des hangars
l'ambiance est nettement moins paisible
dans l'atelier de tonnellerie du centre
france on frappe le bois et le fer et
l'on passe le chêne à l'épreuve du feu
pour en faire des fûts dans lesquelles
seront élevés quelques-uns des meilleurs
vins du monde et tout commence par une
matière première
irréprochable venus souvent d'à peine
quelques dizaines de kilomètres on se
sert dans les trois plus grandes forêts
reconnues dont qui est rond c'est qui
est à quelques encablures d'ici la forêt
de la bertrand ce qui est pas loin non
plus et on travaille aussi avec la forêt
de bercé jupille donc c'est vraiment des
grandes forêts donc on a aussi toutes
les forêts qui sont aux alentours
donc voilà donc on a un beau meyrin qui
est fait chez 24 entre 24 et 36 mois
c'est ce qui va nous faire une grande
barre icap l'entreprise existe depuis
2010 elle a débuté avec trois personnes
et compte aujourd'hui 14 salariés
on y traite chaque année plus de 600
mètres cubes de bois pour produire des
fûts de 225 jusqu'à 600 litres de
contenance le plan de relance se traduit
ici par l'achat de machines plus
performantes un tour à penser bientôt
livré sur le site une nouvelle trace des
gens en fonctionnement et c'est tant pis
leur de douelle qui va faciliter la vie
de ses utilisateurs notamment le bois
tombé par terre et donc la personne
était toujours à travailler
bc ramasser le bois donc c'était
toujours pas donc physiquement pour la
personne ni à gagner et puis aussi on a
gagné un peu de temps dans notre temps
de travail est donc pour nous fait très
très important
chaque jour ces nouveaux investissements
et le savoir faire de ses ouvriers
qualifiés permettent de réaliser plus de
70 barriques de différentes tailles
elles sont vendues dans tous les pays de
tradition viticole en europe mais aussi
aux états unis et jusqu'en nouvelle
zélande